só hoje continuar a fazer o que mais
manilha
eu estou sem fazer isso mas vocês todos
os anos a festa na ilha
só em caso de sobrevivência
sobrevivência alimentar seja só se chega
por vingança e qualquer e estiver com o
inter forma entrei na sala de chá mala
pronta
aí poderá fazer mais um dia qualquer
para apanhar o animal para sobreviver
você pode fazer se a menina em casa viu
um mecanismo treinar mas depois nem que
de montá lo por não buscar uma pessoa
animal que assim totalmente mecanismo se
você for na hora com essa ajuda o da
última vez que você está entre usar a
faca fazer esta espécie no saque as 34 e
pronto o que eu tenho a dizer por que
houve essa medida no canal do senhor
a companhia é sobre sobrevivência eu
foco amigo só ficou sobrevivência
armadilha floresta é realmente um canal
que eu gosto de assistir melhor do que
eu sou muito resumido nas coisas do
filme sobrevivência podem abrir o canal
que não sei o nome do senhor e
pronunciar o nome do canal do cunha
também vou deixar num e o link da
instituição
se vocês quiserem ver eu acho que vocês
tenham uma menina e não ser muito
sensível então eu criei um peso em cima
do animal
smuda para fazer imensos equipe de
armadilhas collaço entrou em outra com
este mecanismo pois o monte e pronto foi
excluir realmente é muito sensível
espero que tenham gostado e até o
próximo